maybe that mild-mannered dude in the
corner was really the big bad guy
perhaps the hero was dead the whole time
or maybe everything we've seen is
somebody's hallucination
whatever the reveal these memorable
movie moments caught us off guard and
left us talking for years to come
spoilers ahead usually movies are told
in chronological order but much like its
protagonist dr. Louise Banks arrival
isn't confined to a single time in the
movies opening we watch Louise lose her
beloved daughter to disease naturally we
assume this is happening early in her
life well before the renowned linguist
is asked by the military to communicate
with the hepta pods mysterious aliens
who've landed on earth her job is to
translate their complex language so
humans can talk with these otherworldly
visitors as she delves deeper into their
circular alphabet though the Hebda pod
language changes her perspective of time
allowing her to experience the past
present and future at once before long
we discover that Louise actually hasn't
had her child yet those flashbacks are
actually flash-forwards
visions of what's to come courtesy of
the alien language Louise now exists
outside of time or more accurately
throughout every moment simultaneously
as a result her perspective on concepts
like love are radically altered by the
hepta pods gift sure she now knows that
heartbreak is coming but she heads into
the future anyway because she knows
there's a lot of joy waiting there too
it might just be the most emotional
twist in all of science fiction and one
that will leave you both thinking and
wiping away a few tears a beautiful mind
finds an oscar-nominated Russell Crowe
playing John Nash a real-life Nobel
Prize winning mathematician who lived a
rather unusual life early in the film
Nash is drafted by Department of Defense
agent William Parcher to analyze
magazines and newspapers for hidden
Russian codes you are quite simply the
best natural code breaker I've ever seen
it's an intense assignment but when he's
not engaged in high-stakes espionage
John seems to lead a normal life for the
supportive voice and an incredibly close
BFF Charles whenever Charles shows up to
visit he brings along his adorable niece
Marcy who always brings a smile to John
face unfortunately of the four most
important people in John's life only one
of them is actually a living breathing
human being in reality John is suffering
from paranoid schizophrenia and the
incredibly creepy Parcher is just a
hallucination there are no secret
messages no Soviet spies lurking in the
shadows and no radium implanted in his
arm
the real blow however is that Charles
and Marcie are also products of his
imagination unless you know the true
story the twist comes as a devastating
surprise and sends this Academy
award-winning film in a disturbing
direction colossal is one of the
strangest movies ever made this fantasy
flick finds Anne Hathaway as the
alcoholic Gloria recently single and
moving back to her hometown but as the
self-destructive woman soon discovers
her problems are a lot bigger than just
the bottle Gloria is psychically linked
to a giant Godzilla like monster and
whenever she stumbles across a
particular playground the kaiju
mysteriously appears in the city of
Seoul South Korea it's dancing is
dancing fortunately Gloria has a good
friend to help with all the booze and
oversized beasts Jason Sudeikis plays
her childhood friend a nice guy named
Oscar the moment Gloria comes back to
town Oscar does everything he can to
help her feel at home he gives her
furniture for her empty house builds her
up with all sorts of compliments and
even gives her a job working at his bar
which is probably not the best place for
an alcoholic to work but then Gloria
realizes there's a lot of darkness
behind Oscars winning smile for one he's
also linked to another giant creature
that appears in the South Korean capital
and while he pretends to be a good dude
we quickly learned he's a violent
manipulative control freak more
monstrous than any kaiju and when Gloria
tries to get away from this creep he
threatens to murder countless Koreans
with his robot avatar did you drink that
beer I'll go take a walk through the
park later this turn from best friend to
abuser is pretty shocking largely thanks
to Sudeikis affable persona that said
there were probably a lot of women who
saw this coming well aware that the real
world is full of Oscars one of the most
unsettle
sci-fi movies ever made ex machina finds
a mild-mannered computer programmer
named Caleb winning the contest of a
lifetime he's been picked to spend a
week conducting a bizarre Turing test
with his billionaire boss Nathan played
here by a super creepy show stealing
Oscar Isaac a brilliant inventor nathan
has created an artificial intelligence
named Ava and he wants to see if his
creation can convince Caleb she's
essentially and being Caleb quickly
falls under Ava's spell and soon the
programmer plans to free his crush from
Nathan's grasp do you have people a test
you might switch you off no oh why do I
after all the tech tycoon has her locked
up and plans on essentially killing her
plus Nathan's interest in Ava isn't just
scientific this guy has a thing for
building female robots that he can
imprison and control using his own tech
savvy Caleb sets Ava free and seconds
later the liberated Android slices
through Nathan like he's a Pat of hot
butter if this was your typical sci-fi
flick Ava and Caleb would probably run
off together but an ex machina things
take a hard left turn when Ava locks up
Caleb and leaves the screaming
programmer to die of starvation it's a
gut punch of an ending especially since
Caleb seems so sympathetic sadly there's
a good chance that he would have
jeopardized her shot at freedom in the
outside world in the end he had to be
tested and switched off after all it's
no surprise that the Armitage family are
the bad guys and get out when Missy
Armitage and her husband Dean first meet
our everyman hero Chris Washington
they're way too friendly and far too
polite which is never a good sign in a
horror movie by the way I I would have
voted for Obama for a third term if I
could best president my life to have
hands down I agree then there's their
super creepy son Jeremy who's boozing
with menace whenever he comes slinking
on to the screen but with all these
racists surrounding poor Chris his
girlfriend Rose seems totally on his
side she'll definitely help him escape
her family's clutches right
unfortunately Rose is probably the most
evil member of the entire family
after finding a box of incriminating
photos Chris starts to realize he's the
victim of some
really cruel catfishing but he still
desperately hopes that Rose is on a
syphon armitage clan blocks his path he
begs rose to give him the car keys so he
can escape and for a moment it seems
like she might pick her boyfriend over
her own flesh and blood she doesn't know
she's rose you know I can't give you a
kiss for a pic the casting here is what
makes the twist work so well according
to both allison williams and director
Jordan Peele
Williams was cast because audiences
would associate her with the far less
evil roles that she'd played before sure
enough she does indeed seem pretty
harmless right up until she doesn't
messing around with creepy European
cults is never a good idea that's a
lesson our murderous antihero learns the
hard way in Ben Wheatley's kill list
this disturbing horror film is centred
around Jay a family man whose marriage
has fallen on hard times and oh yeah he
makes his living as a hired killer
you've got to put food on the table
somehow and Jay stands to make a tidy
paycheck by killing three people for a
mysterious client who wants his contract
signed in blood the weird thing is the
targets don't behave like typical
victims instead of begging for their
lives they actually thanked Jay when he
shows up for some hammer time things go
from eerie to straight-up hellish when
Jay tries to kill his third victim
instead of finding his target he
stumbles into a cult right out of the
wicker man the whole assassination
scheme was part of an elaborate occult
ritual and it comes to a bloody end when
the pagans captured Jay put a mask over
his face and force him to fight a
cloaked hunchback the assassin makes
short work of his opponent but after
turning this guy into a shish kebab Jay
discovers a horrific truth The Hunchback
is really his wife and son kidnapped by
the cult and tied together with his son
on his wife's back Jay just murdered his
own family much to the delight of the
deranged cult capping off a gas leak
film with a truly gruesome ending
bong Joon hos mother has a pretty
standard plot for a murder mystery a
mentally challenged young man is accused
of murdering a teenage girl the police
don't have any solid evidence against
him but they need to make an arrest
so they toss the disabled man in
and trick him into confessing needless
to say his devoted mother knows her son
is innocent
and she goes from a mild-mannered Widow
to South Korea's Sherlock Holmes chasing
down leads interrogating suspects and
putting together a case to free her son
from jail
she even discovers a possible scheme
involving blackmail and a mysterious old
man now in your typical murder mystery
the mom would discover the killer's true
identity and clear her kid's name
however mother subverts all those
expectations when the titular mom makes
a simple but shocking discovery her son
really did it yeah he's a sweet kid and
yes he's mentally disabled but that
didn't stop him from caving in a girl's
head it's a smart little twist that gets
even twistier when the mom murders an
eyewitness to protect her son mother
spins every thriller trope on its head
but it also goes to show that nobody
loves you like your mother every knife
wielding villain in a horror movie has a
special talent for taking out their
victims when they least expect it but
ghosts face the sinister slasher from
1996 his scream seems like he could pop
up anywhere at any time
when the masked killer first arrives in
the opening scene after terrorizing poor
drew barrymore over the phone he seems
to be lurking around every single corner
there's no way anyone can move this
quickly but as victim after victim
learns there's no getting away from
Ghost Face this dude is everywhere
please don't kill me mr. ghost face I
want to be the sequel in the big climax
of Wes Craven's horror classic we
discover the secret behind ghosts faces
teleporting powers final girl Sidney
Prescott is running for her life the
mass murderer has shown up at a high
school party and he's slicing people
left and right Sidney has no clue who's
under the mask and we have plenty of
suspects Ghostface could be boyfriend
Billy horror movie fan Randy goofballs
do or even Sidney's own dad there are so
many suspects and it's impossible to
know who to trust
and that's when Sidney makes a horrific
discovery her boyfriend Billy is
Ghostface and so is his best bud stew
these two psychos are working together
for a maximum kill count and providing
each other with an alibi
these don't create psychos
psychos with two guys running around
wearing ghost face masks it's no wonder
this bad guy was making such good time M
night Shyamalan extremely weird
filmography has made him a punchline for
many moviegoers but he'll always have
one indisputable claim to fame he made
The Sixth Sense an all-time great horror
movie with possibly the most famous
twist and cinematic history the film
finds Bruce Willis playing dr. Malcolm
Crowe an award-winning child
psychologist in the opening scene he's
shot by a disturbed patient he couldn't
save but a couple of months later Crowe
was walking around and seems perfectly
okay well his marriage is falling apart
and his wife won't acknowledge his
existence so that isn't great but at
least he gets a chance at redemption by
helping cool sear a troubled boy who can
well you know however Cole isn't the
only one who can see spirits the
audience has been looking at a dead guy
since the start of the movie after
trying so hard to talk to his wife Crowe
finally realizes why she won't respond
he's a ghost that gun shot in the
beginning of the film was actually fatal
and he's been a dead man walking ever
since despite never realizing it himself
it was an ending that sent shockwaves
through Hollywood and Shyamalan has been
trying to recapture that glory ever
since
but while the film r2 has come close The
Sixth Sense still stands supreme as the
perfect Shyamalan twist
everybody knows the twist from The
Empire Strikes Back
even moviegoers who have never seen a
single Star Wars movie know Darth Vader
is actually Luke Skywalker's dad the
twist has permeated the pop-culture
consciousness and given us one of the
most memorable and misquoted lines of
all time
Luke I am your father back in 1980
however the Luke Vader revelation
absolutely floored Star Wars fans most
of the cast and crew didn't even know
the truth about Luke's family tree
according to Mark Hamill the original
script read differently the way we
filmed it Vader said you don't know the
truth obi-wan killed your father
famously only Hamill James Earl Jones
George Lucas and director Irvin Kershner
were aware of the twist so when Vader
finally announced his parentage
everybody was gasping from audiences to
the actors themselves and this shocking
moment did a whole lot more than elicit
gasps the dad Vader reveals sent the
series in a completely new direction and
laid the groundwork for countless
additional Star Wars films as any other
movie twists had such an enormous impact
the last jetta is one of the twistiest
chapters in the entire Star Wars
franchise
we learned that Rey's parents are
nobodies big bad Snoke gets cut in half
Luke was a force induced illusion the
whole time it's twist after crazy twists
but the biggest shock comes early in the
film when Luke Skywalker reveals his
Jedi days are done
to set the scene we have to go back to a
long long time ago to 2015 when the
force awakens was teasing audiences with
the promise of Luke Skywalker it had
been over 30 years since fans had seen
the beloved Jedi Knight and the entire
premise of episode 7 involved the group
of heroes searching for the legendary
warrior finally at the end of the film
ray finds the bearded Skywalker standing
on a majestic cliff as that John
Williams music starts to swell Rey hands
the Jedi his long-lost lightsaber and
that's where the film ends with Rey
reaching out to the hooded silent hero
audiences had to wait two whole years to
see what would happen
but obviously Luke was gonna take the
lightsaber and lead the charge against
the first order right not exactly in the
years since he last saw him Luke has
turned his back on the force and wants
the Jedi to die out this little twist
flew in the face of fans expectations
but really they should have listened
when Yoda told us all those years ago
that the Jedi were never meant to be
great warriors if terry gilliam Karl
Marx Spike Lee and Rod Serling all
teamed up to make a movie
might look like sorry to bother you
written and directed by boots Riley this
movie is absolutely insane in all the
right ways and no description can do it
justice it is without a doubt the most
anti-capitalist film to ever come out of
Hollywood and it features perhaps the
most deranged twists of the 21st century
so far the plot follows a promising
young telemarketer named cassius cash
green who finds success in sales by
smooth-talking his customers using with
the film calls his voice voice thank you
hey mr. Kramer this is licensing from
regal view I didn't catch you at the
wrong time did I soon cash is promoted
to the big time which involves selling
slaves to giant companies and eventually
he crosses paths with a psycho
billionaire played by Armie Hammer with
big plans for the future of business up
until this point the movie has been
incredibly weird but when cash discovers
the billionaires plans the film
absolutely loses its mind as it turns
out the billionaire is turning people
into half-human half-horse monsters so
he can create a powerful but malleable
work force that's right armie hammer is
turning people into horses and if that
wasn't wild enough the movie ends with
cash suddenly turning into an equestrian
himself
it's totally bonkers and no matter how
good you are at guessing twists you'll
never see this nightmare coming from the
Mandarin reveal an Iron Man 3 to the
Thanos snap and Infinity Ward the MCU
had its fair share of shocking twists
one of its most jaw-dropping moments
however comes in spider-man homecoming
when Peter Parker picks up his date for
the homecoming dance and finds something
way more intimidating than the average
suburban death throughout this superhero
flick the wall crawler is trying to find
a balance between homework and
crime-fighting
hanging out with friends and trading
punches with bad guys you can't really
go to parties or participate in the
academic decathlon and you've got an
entire neighborhood to protect and it's
hard to get a date when you're
constantly trying to fight the vulture a
winged thief who sells weapons made with
alien technology to local thugs
eventually Peter puts his crime-fighting
on pause and works up the nerve to ask
his crush lizallen to the dance
he gets his suit learns to dance my's
lose a nice corsage and shows up at her
house ready for a fun evening that's
when the door open
to reveal the vulture himself as it
turns out this murderous villain just so
happens to be Liz's father suddenly
Peter isn't worried about making a good
impression he's just worried about
making it through the night alive which
becomes even more difficult when the
vulture realizes why Peters acting even
more nervous than the usual high school
kid meeting his girlfriend's father very
lucky that he was there that day
don't spider-man like Uncle Ben always
used to say with great power comes a
really complicated love life check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]